Сонячні панелі дозволяють українським родинам
заощаджувати та заробляти, кажуть
у Державному агентстві з енергоефективності та енергозбереження.
За словами голови Держенергоефективності Сергія Савчука,
якщо встановити у домогосподарстві
сонячну станцію потужністю до 30 кВт,
то можна не лише забезпечити свій будинок енергією,
але й продавати її надлишок у загальну мережу
за «зеленим» тарифом та отримувати щомісяця
прибуток у 20-30 тисяч гривень.
Ми вирішили перевірити, чи справді це так.
Можливість заробляти на сонці з’явилась у 2015 році,
коли ухвалили Закон "Про альтернативні джерела енергії".
Віталій Несенюк одразу перевірив дію цього закону
і став першим киянином, який підписав угоду з енергокомпаніями.
Установив ось цю станцію потужністю 10кВт
і витратив на неї близько 10 тисяч доларів.
За три роки він ще не окупив свої витрати.
Це пасивний заробіток. Це принципово, що це є інвестиція.
Тобто треба вкласти чималі гроші,
десь від 10 тисяч доларів до 50
і треба розуміти, що 7 років ці гроші будуть обертатись і потім,
після 7 років, уже буде чистий прибуток.
Це цілком вигідні умови, упевнені чиновники.
За офіційними даними, за три роки
кількість сонячних станцій, встановлених
приватними домогосподарствами,
зросла із понад ста до 3,5 тисяч,
тобто майже у 30 разів.
В Україні близько 6,5 млн приватних домогосподарств.
Це величезний ринок для розвитку альтернативних джерел енергії.
Утім, якщо врахувати середню заробітну місячну плату,
яка, за даними мінфіну, становить трохи більше 8 тисяч гривень,
інвестувати 10 тисяч доларів, як це зробив  Віталій,
можуть далеко не всі. Частіше за все таку інвестицію
можуть дозволити собі представники малого та середнього бізнесу.
Утім, Віталій зауважує, що почати можна і з меншої суми.
Стартувати з 2 тисяч доларів - це можливо.
заключити договір на станцію потужністю 1-2 кВт,
і казати, що "вау, я зараз енергоефективний",
але зиску з цього мало.
Тому що, по-перше, треба перевершити своє споживання.
Тобто така математика, що
нормальною станцією вважається в середньому 10-15 кВт.
І тоді  ви будете мати надлишки десь 70-100 тисяч на рік
і не будете мати рахунків на електрику.
У залежності від погоди та пори року його станція у 10 кВт
у середньому дає до 600 євро доходу щомісяця,
або по 20 євроцентів з кожного виробленого кВт.
Прив'язка «зеленого тарифу» до курсу євро -
це плюс таких інвестицій.
Інша перевага: будинок повністю забезпечений енергією.
За нинішнім тарифом Віталій мав би
сплачувати за електрику близько 500 гривень щомісяця.
А тепер не витрачає на це ні копійки.
Чоловік планує інвестувати в енергію сонця й надалі.
Він вже встановив іншу станцію потужністю 3 кВт.
Утім, за рахунок рухомої конструкції
вона майже не поступається 10 кВт.
Його мета - досягнути 30 кВТ, дозволених для домашніх господарств.
Українці справді можуть заробляти 20-30 тисяч гривень щомісяця на енергії сонця.
Утім, як показує практика, для отримання таких прибутків
необхідно витратити не менше 30 тисяч доларів
на станцію максимальної потужності для домашніх господарств у 30 кВт.
По-друге, окупності цих інвестицій чекати понад 7 років.